the Apple watch has been a massive
success for Apple over the years even
accounting for a huge sixty percent of
the global Smartwatch Revenue last year
but there's a pretty big problem it
seems like the Innovation for the Apple
watch is slowing down rapidly with the
new series 8 model being essentially
identical to this series 7 except for
two minor features and the new S8 chip
is just a rebranded S7 which was already
just a rebranded S6 but thankfully I've
been digging through all of Apple's
interesting Apple watch patents and it
looks like they've got some really
Innovative changes coming to the Apple
watch was that you probably didn't even
know were possible but they are so let's
dig right into it here's the first one
showing off that Apple invented a new
laser-based rotation sensor for the
digital crown for greater rotational
accuracy and more which right now with
the regular Apple watch when you spin it
really fast it skips some of the actual
situations or sensing of the spin so
this would essentially fix that issue as
you can see right here with the current
digital Crown here's the next one
talking about micro LED displays coming
to Apple's devices including the Apple
watch which I believe it makes sense for
it to come to the Apple watch first
because it has basically the smallest
display out of any Apple device so it's
going to be the cheapest and easiest to
do and then it'll make its way to the
other Apple products like the iPhone
later on now this right here is a really
cool patent Apple invented a system
where the actual band is gonna have NFC
modules just like the Apple Mac safe
wallet that's connected with NFC so when
you put it on the back of the iPhone it
pops up and it shows that it's connected
imagine you put on an Apple watch band
and your UI and apps or basically your
watch face changes to the color of the
band that you buy but this pattern right
here absolutely Takes the Cake this is
unbelievable but check this out there's
going to be a new fabric watch band
which has an electrochromic feature that
allows users to set three colors and
three band zones so you can see right
here on your watch you're gonna choose
different colors and literally your
watch band will change color to match
your face not the other way around but
the actual band itself will be able to
change colors I don't know how this is
possible apparently they have all these
filaments that are inside of the layers
of fabric kind of interwoven and they
can change color but even crazier Apple
invented a smart metal and fabric health
and Communications band for the Apple
watch and maybe even a future mixed
reality headset where you can see
there's electrodes and conductive paths
within the actual Apple watch band it's
self so that means there's circuitry
flowing through it and it is going to be
able to do certain specific things which
I'm going to show you in more of these
patterns as you can see right here
here's a pattern for a future Apple
watch band that includes batteries yes
batteries inside of the band itself
which could extend the battery life of
the Apple watch or power more actual
features for the watch itself even
crazier here's a pattern where they show
you disconnecting the band and literally
plugging it into a MacBook to recharge
the band or your actual Apple watch or
maybe even share files apparently and
they even mentioned adding Touch ID to
the display and I'm gonna get back to
that in a minute because there are more
patents talking about that but first
let's talk about more of the band
features this pattern right here blows
my mind Apple wanna gotten for a watch
band with an adjustable fit system for
casual and sports use and keeping Health
sensors in position this band will be
able to automatically adjust the
tightness of a band without active user
input so literally you put on the loose
band and it tightens up to match your
wrist perfectly and then this invention
is something that matches the tensioning
band where you'll basically have a
confirmation screen where it'll show if
it's locked or tightened and now here's
another one that says the Apple watch
could support face ID and have specific
Sports Performance analysis via in band
sensors which you can see capacitive
sensors right here on the inside of the
band not only that but you have these
EMG sensors basically built into the
band measuring different sports
analytics and apparently they even
patented using Those sensors the em
sensors within it to detect the actual
hand gestures that you do so if you move
it to one side it can detect that by
basically measuring your muscle strain
right here in your wrist knowing exactly
what you're doing and this could
probably even be used for the VR headset
or something else and the really cool
thing in this patent image is that it
shows the new band contacts for
connectors you can see all these little
pins along the side or the edge of the
Apple watch band and you can see the
actual Apple watch has all of these
connectors you slide it in boom it's
connected and that is how I can imagine
it working with all of the built-in
batteries all of the sensors everything
that's built into the Apple watch and
then here's another one that shows the
Smart Fabric patent from Apple showing
how health sensors could be integrated
into the band itself so you could see
that they're going to be skin facing
sensors blood oxygen heart rate and and
this is even crazier right here you can
use your Apple watch to basically scan
the band that you have which will have
some sort of ID element on the band
itself and then it'll know which
features your band will support within
your actual Apple watch and this patent
kinda says the same thing but it goes
even deeper where you have your Apple
watch sensors that connect to the Apple
watch band sensor so if you go down to
this image you can see that you'll have
another sort of sensor module built in
to the band itself so that way you have
both of them working at the same time
and it'll carry all the signals and data
through those conductors or electrical
wiring over to the Apple watch so for
example right here you can see
multi-pixel pvdf strain capacitive Gap
sensors embedded in or around the back
portion basically giving you more
accurate measurements or or even new
features potentially and then this right
here is a banger Apple filed for a
patent showing a new blood pressure
monitoring system that includes a liquid
filled sensor now this right here is
absolutely amazing because you see the
module that's on the other side of the
watch so you have your Apple watch on
the top and right where your wrist is
where you have a very thin skin and
arteries it could actually measure your
blood pressure directly through that and
the coolest part about this is that
Apple can sell you the new Apple watch
let's say it's the series nine and then
they sell a specialty band for those who
want to constantly measure their blood
pressure without having to constantly
put on that thing that measures the
pressure everything else you could just
buy this band for extra money instead of
a regular band and there you go you have
it automated and apple can do so many
different things with this idea of
having specific bands for specific
features that you can unlock and one of
those I believe is gonna be the blood
glucose monitoring system which Apple's
been working on for many many years
since 2015 and now they have a
breakthrough in terms of the light that
is used special photonics that is very
powerful and it could help them actually
measure the blood glucose levels in your
system and I think they'll integrate it
in the same way where they have another
secondary module that will be attached
on it sold separately so that way people
who don't care about it they don't need
to pay for it the people who do care
about it buy the Special Band for extra
money that's a genius genius solution
and now let's get into the touch ID
pattern that I mentioned earlier check
this out they patented a new beam
forming technology where you will have
Touch ID on the display and not just a
specific spot the entire display shaded
in yellow literally put your finger here
anywhere on that section of your Apple
watch and there you go you can integrate
Touch ID even better they apparently
have Palm ID Biometrics for the Apple
watch so you'll literally just put your
poem above your Apple watch and somehow
it'll be able to scan your palm and know
that it's you that just sounds
mind-blowing but apparently look at
these patents these are directly from
Apple they can scan all of your
Biometrics right on your Apple watch and
say welcome Bob and this pattern right
here is a genius idea a future Apple
watch that could literally detach from
the band so you can charge the Apple
watch while the band continues to stay
on your wrist to track Biometrics now
you might ask why in the world would you
want your band to stay on well sleep
tracking which doesn't use that much
power that way you could still charge
your Apple watch while you're sleeping
and you don't have a heavy watch on you
just have a band that's comfortable to
sleep with and that way every single
night you're tracking your sleep because
right now many people complain that they
have to charge it and they don't want to
do that because it dies in the morning
and they have to leave this is the
perfect perfect solution even crazier
it's mentioning the Apple watch having a
built-in camera in a unique band system
where you can detach your Apple watch
set it up on a table and just like you
see here take a photo of yourself using
your Apple watches camera and I know
you're probably thinking a camera on an
Apple Watch that sounds insane well take
a look at this apple is working on it
you can see basically a camera within
your Apple watch with face ID and
FaceTime taking videos and much more
built into a future Apple watch now I
have no idea when this is gonna come but
apparently right here you can stick a
camera right on your Apple watch and
apple is working on it right now so as
you can see that was a lot of patents
and here is the general idea from all of
them these patents prove where Apple's
mind is headed their mind is headed
towards having new bands that work
electronically actually having
conductors and electrical paths that
connect to the Apple watch itself to
enable new features like automatic
tensioning and new health sensors maybe
blood glucose blood pressure that is
where apple is going to sell you more
products with your Apple watch which is
a great idea and of course they have the
whole Touch ID face ID ideas and micro
LED displays so no The Innovation is not
over for the Apple watch they are still
going and we might even see some of
these patents later this year with the
Apple Watch series 9 fine let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below and definitely subscribe
for more videos and check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign